i love you henry thank you buddy i'm
here with
will aj and henry jo who went viral
after will asked his brother henry jo to
be his best man
will you please say yes to be my best
man that
will you want to be my best man
how are you guys dealing with this
newfound thing the word we keep using is
surreal and our initial goal was
to spread this positive moment with our
friends and family
and it just kind of turned into the rest
of the world so even
gabrielle union tweeted about you guys
carl weathers is another one
guy who is henry jo
you're a celebrity now how do you feel
about that
i'm so honored that i'm part of this
interview but
i'm so happy that i have a brother that
makes me special you hit something
who came up with this idea to put a
message in a bottle
well do you please no
so to be completely honest it was an
idea i had had about initially proposing
to
my fiance aj i have two older sisters
and i talked with them we decided it
might be a little more special to have
something a little more intimate so
i took aj on the boat and asked her to
be my wife in that way but i kept this
in my back pocket
metal detecting detecting's his favorite
hobby right now we got him to ask
will to go metal detecting with him so
he thought it was his idea
everything worked out perfectly
there was no debate in my mind that
henry was going to be my best man
did his reaction exceed or live up to
your expectations it was bigger than i
thought but to be completely honest with
you we've known henry's a special guy
for a long time
um that's exactly who he is and he'll
give you
heartwarming um memories and moments
like that every day
that is so creative dear will i love
that
thank you you're welcome bubba oh you
guys are so sweet i love it
so much um why was henry joe
the perfect pick for your best man he is
just a beam of light and
positivity in our lives i understood
henry before anyone else could
we kind of had that non-verbal brother
communication going so
we've been on the same way wavelength
for a long time
i'm two years older than him but he's a
he's a great role model of mine just by
the way he lives his life and how he
treats others henry jo
what does it mean to you to be your
brother's best man
are you so excited i'm so excited
because
um i really care about
this allison moment um we are
all the greatest couples it must be so
great
to be so close to these brothers and get
to see their bond
what can you tell us about that
brotherly friendship that they have
yeah so i'm a special education teacher
and so when i started dating will and
found out that henry was his brother i
was like
wow like it's just a match made in
husband and then seeing
their relationship and how much they
lean on each other how much they look
after each other
it's just like you couldn't ask for
anything else in a brotherly lover
brotherly bond
did you guys set your date yet yeah
7 17 21 so stay tuned i mean this was a
pretty epic moment
how are you going to top that at the
wedding weddings are where henry thrives
he will tear it up on the dance floor
he is excellent at giving speeches we'll
have to videotape the best
man speech and share that again with
folks because i'm sure they're going to
want to hear it
henry jo what are you most excited for
for the wedding
so excited because um i can't wait to
see um a lot of cake um
impressions and this is amazing because
this is a gift because um running is a
gift
that women ages on so i'm so sad i love
it and you're going to tear up that
dance floor